I think the most sympathetic argument to
Rishi sunak is that he's had to deal
with a lot of external factors and he
has to clean up clean up a lot of other
people's economic messiness Boris
Johnson Liz trusts to name a few people
he has been put in really difficult
circumstances that is the argument he's
always made right when he was hiking
corporation tax in the March budget for
um you know when he's been growing the
size of the state doing all of these
handouts he's always been saying I'm
forced to do it the question I'm asking
this week is well you're in charge now
and can we really claim everything
that's happening is something that
you're being forced to do two examples I
use are the child care handout to middle
class families 33 hours a week and and
also if we look at what's going to
happen to the welfare bill under the new
projections from this last budget which
was Jeremy Hunt overseen by Rishi sunak
it's increasing by 16 over the next four
years it's going to go up to 330 billion
pounds
um I see that as a political choice